america's amazing you know i really felt
like as a show that has always kind of
represented
real life stories and very real people i
liked the opportunity
that we got to kind of address something
that would happen
like that happens in these stores you
form these bonds you work with these
people for years and years and years and
then
people move on people get other jobs
people move away
the harder i try to replace you the more
i realize that uh
maybe you're not replaceable i don't
know that's probably wrong
yeah i was just tired or something and i
really loved you know the moments that
we got to have with dina and amy
um at the beginning of the season as amy
was leaving you don't have to get
married right away
wait a couple years oh we could have a
double wedding the theme is winter
lumber mill
it's not negotiable i think the real
love story over a lot of those seasons
was the friendship between dina and amy
and i think it was a really cool thing
oh we're best friends yeah well i mean
i'm yours
you're my number four and technically i
count twins as one person six seasons is
a real accomplishment yeah what's the
mix of emotions for you
knowing that it was coming to a close i
think no matter when it was if it was
now
if it was in a year if it was in three
years i think it's always going to be
very emotional you know it's a loss you
see these people more than you see your
loved ones so it's weird to then one day
just go
bye guess what you know you know we've
been notorious for
you know singing between takes there's a
lot of hamilton that's gone on a lot of
drake singing
you know just fun and just like hanging
out you know that's the thing that i
always say that it's like
i always feel like i'm going to get to
hang out with my friends and we just
happen to make a tv show in the process
i think it's very rare and i think that
it was never lost on any of us